- Welcome all to our final
event of the semester
and of the year.
My name is Dr. Ty Kamp,
and I'm assistant director
of the Franke Program in
Science and the Humanities.
We're delighted that this year
we've started gathering
in person once again
for our signature public talks
and convivial receptions,
I think, for which we are known.
It's through the magnanimity
of our benefactors
Mr. and Mrs. Richard
Franke and Barbara Franke
that we have produced
such robust programming,
talks ranging from such
diverse topics as overfishing
on the Mexican Peninsula
to the Salvator Mundi,
the Leonardo da Vinci's lost
painting we learned about
a few months ago, to the
history of CGI in movies,
to novel, interdisciplinary
approaches to architecture
and the built environment.
We hope you've enjoyed this year of talks
and intellectual exchange at
the boundaries ever permeable
between the sciences and the humanities.
Before I introduce today's
talk by Dr. Michael Caplan,
I'm required to give this
rather officious notice.
Yale University is photographing
and videotaping this event.
There's a possibility you may
be included in these visuals,
so by being present
during these activities,
you consent to the use of
your appearance, likeness,
and voice by Yale University
for standard, nonprofit,
educational, news-related promotional
and/or editorial purposes.
It's rather legalistic, but
our videographer is a lawyer,
so thank you, Guy.
Could you tell?
Also, as per usual, we shall be gathering
for our dinner reception
upstairs in Fellows Hall tonight,
not the student lounge,
but Frederick Young,
Frederick will shepherd
you there after the event,
so please do stay for dinner.
Our guest today is
Professor Michael Caplan,
the C.N.H. Long Professor
of cellular and molecular physiology,
and professor of cell biology
at Yale School of Medicine,
where he's also the chair
of cellular and molecular physiology.
Michael received his bachelor's
degree from Harvard in 1980,
and his MD and PhD
degrees from Yale in 1987,
so we can praise him on that
proper academic trajectory,
going from Harvard to Yale.
Sorry, I couldn't help it.
He joined Yale's department of
cellular molecular physiology
as a faculty member in 1988,
and has received fellowships
from the Helen Hay Whitney Foundation,
the David and Lucile Packard Foundation
for science and engineering,
and a national Young Investigator Award
from the National Science Foundation.
He has also received the
Young Investigator Awards
from the American Physiological Society
and the American Society of Nephrologists.
Michael's work focuses
on understanding the ways
in which kidney cells organize
and maintain their unique structures.
His laboratory also studies
the mechanisms responsible
for autosomal dominant
polycystic kidney disease,
and they're working to identify
targets for new therapies,
really groundbreaking and applicable work
of import for us all.
So his biography, it's all as
cerebral as it is laudatory,
but I can tell you from
personal experience,
having worked in his lab many years ago,
that Michael is every bit as generous
and supportive a mentor and
professor as he is accomplished
and absolutely brilliant,
the evidence of which
you will soon discover.
He's also very, very funny,
so I hope he'll share
some of his brand of humor with us.
As this is our final
gathering until September,
when, by the way, we shall
be hosting a screening
of "My Octopus Teacher,"
maybe you've heard of this from Netflix,
we'll be bringing in
the filmmaker for that,
so put it on your
calendar, September 14th.
I just wanna take a little
bit of time to recognize
some very important colleagues of ours,
some of whom are here.
Tony Sudol, whose technical expertise
makes our events possible.
Rick Leone and his
colleagues at Yale Broadcast,
especially our videographer
today, Guy Ortoleva.
They record our events and they turn them
into wonderful videos that
receive many, many views
on Yale's YouTube channel and our website.
Matthew Jacob and the staff
at Coromandel Indian Cuisine
who cater our receptions,
David Suraci and his family
at Fitzgerald's Florist
in West Haven because they
ensure that our program
has arguably the best floral arrangements
of all Yale events, and
that's pretty high standard.
And also my colleagues at
the Whitney Humanities Center
who lend us tremendous
support each and every event
and throughout the year,
Matthew Hagan in particular,
Inessa Laskova, Sandra
Malan-Bowles, Diane Brown,
they do wonderful work and they
do their jobs enviably well.
And finally, Tanisha Leal and
Jamar, the custodial staff,
for their wonderful
support and professionalism
for all our events.
So without further ado, Michael,
would you please come up
for your talk, and please
join me in welcoming him.
(audience clapping)
- Thank you so much.
So thank you all for coming,
and thanks especially
to Ty for the invitation
and the opportunity to talk to you today.
I am going to try to convince
you that the old expression,
art imitates life, can be
read in both directions,
and that life imitates art also,
and that some of what's
going on inside of us
and inside of ourselves
is extraordinarily aesthetically
pleasing and can teach us,
by looking at it as an aesthetic object,
it can teach us something,
not only about how it works,
but also why it's there.
But I wanna begin with a
little bit of an introduction
to the discipline we're
gonna be talking about
and its history.
So the question is, what is physiology?
These are two of my favorite illustrations
to try and address that question.
The picture on the right,
which we're gonna talk about
a little bit more, is from
the first systematic study
of anatomy by Vesalius.
It was drawn in the
1600s, and I love the idea
of a skeleton contemplating itself.
And to the left, there's a picture
by the wonderful graphic artist Ben Shahn,
which is referred to as "The Scientist."
And again, for me,
the integration of the
image of the scientist
with the work that the scientist is doing
is especially pleasing.
So physiology is arguably the oldest
of the biomedical sciences.
Depending on where you
wanna start counting,
it could arguably be
credited back to Hippocrates,
about 2,400 years ago,
and it could be credibly said
that Hippocrates was
the first physiologist.
Subsequently Galen, about
in the second century CE,
was the first person to
really develop theories
about the circulation of
the blood in the body,
and he had the opportunity
to develop his theories
by watching what happened
to some of the less successful
of the Roman gladiators,
and that allowed him to learn a little bit
about what happened
when blood was allowed to
leave its normal vessels.
In the 1500s, again, we have Vesalius,
whose name actually means the weasel.
That was the family coat
of arms, and actually,
if you visit
the Yale School of Medicine's
historical library,
his coat of arms is on the far wall,
and it's three weasels chasing each other.
Don't ask me why.
I don't know if he gave himself that name
or if he owed some debts
and it was given to him by his creditors,
but Vesalius wrote the first
systematic book of anatomy
called "De Humani Corporis
Fabrica Libri Septum."
This is a picture of a dissection going on
in Vesalius' laboratory,
which was in Bologna in Italy.
You can still visit it today,
and it's an extraordinary anatomy theater.
Fortunately, it no longer
smells as it probably did
at the time that this sketch was made.
And you can see Vesalius right here,
who's leading the dissection.
So Vesalius was really the first person
who tried to understand anatomy,
and relate it to physiology
and how things work.
And this is the frontispiece
from that first anatomy,
"De Corpore Humanis."
And there is actually an
original copy of this book,
which is entirely priceless,
in Yale's medical historical library.
So I encourage you to go to the library,
I encourage you to ask to see it,
and I encourage you to not be
disappointed when they say no.
(audience laughing)
William Harvey's book on
the circulation of the blood
from the early 1600s,
Harvey was at Oxford,
and he was the first person
who really began to figure out
the relationship between
the heart, the lungs,
and the pulmonary and the
systemic circulations.
Although it can be said
that Arab scholars,
including Ibn as-Nafis,
proposed similar ideas
much earlier in the 13th century.
Luigi Galvani, who also worked in Bologna,
and whose laboratory you can also visit,
around the time of the
enlightenment in the mid 1700s,
he and his wife, working together,
discovered that electrical signals
prompt muscle contraction.
And it was really he and his work,
or he and his wife and
their work that gave rise
to the concept of bioelectricity
and the field of electrophysiology,
which is one of the most prominent fields
in biomedical science today.
And it's interesting to think about
what was the physiologic system
that Galvani chose to study.
And those of you who are looking carefully
can see his experimental
preparation down here.
It is half a frog.
So Galvani used the
bottom halves of frogs.
And back in the day of Benjamin Franklin,
instead of flying a kite,
he attracted electricity
and hooked it up to a frog.
You can see two different frogs
hooked up to lightning rods here,
and he saw that atmospheric
static electricity
was able to cause twitchy
movements in the frog legs,
giving rise to the idea
that electricity was somehow important
in how our muscles contracted,
and ultimately, in how nerves conducted.
And it wasn't really until the 1950s,
the work of Hodgkin-Huxley
in cats in England
that led us to understand
how electricity is coupled
to the action of nerves and muscles.
More recently, William
Beaumont can be seen
as the first American to
pursue studies of physiology.
And in fact, if you visit
Yale Medical School,
when you're done looking at
the Vesalius family crest,
if you go up a flight of stairs,
there's a large conference
room at the Medical School
called the Beaumont Room, with
a portrait of Beaumont in it.
Beaumont actually, as far as anyone knows,
never set foot at Yale,
but he was highly admired,
and so there's a whole room
and a whole portrait of him.
Beaumont's claim to fame was
that he was in the right place
at the right time, and a
guy named Alexis St. Martin
was in the wrong place at the wrong time.
So St. Martin was a soldier
in the Canadian military
who caught a piece of
shrapnel in the abdomen.
He survived, and when the wound healed,
it created, what's called, a fistula
that connected his stomach
to the outside world.
So this poor guy was walking around
and was able to actually live a normal,
reasonably healthy life, but
gastric juice was dripping
out of this fistula.
Beaumont had the wisdom to recognize
that maybe by collecting
it and measuring it,
it could tell us something about
what controls the secretion
of material into the stomach.
And in fact, Beaumont
did the first experiments
on the relationship between
the brain and acid secretion
in the stomach before Pavlov
did his famous experiments
with his dog.
So here's a picture of Beaumont draining,
I don't know, hopefully you
can, well, let me try this.
So there's a picture of
Beaumont draining gastric acid
from an unfortunate, but very
patient Alexis St. Martin.
And I should say that there's
a large color painting
of Beaumont in the Beaumont Room,
and a small sketch of Alexis St. Martin,
even though, in point of
fact, he and his courage
probably deserve the
lion's share of the credit.
More recently and more
relevant to this talk
are the two people who are seen
as the founders of modern physiology.
So Claude Bernard was a French scientist
who coined the term milieu interieur,
and by that he meant that we as organisms
who live in an air environment
are yet made up of 60% water.
So we carry within us a volume of fluid
that is critically important
for how every cell in our body works,
and he recognized that a large fraction
of what our bodies do is work
to persist the composition,
to maintain the composition of that fluid,
because maintaining the
composition of that fluid
is critically important
to all of the other physiologic processes
that get carried out in the body.
So his idea was that the maintenance
of the milieu interieur,
the interior milieu,
is the main function of all
of our physiologic systems.
Walter Cannon, who was a scientist
in the first part of the
20th century at Harvard,
coined the term homeostasis
to mean the same thing.
In other words, we have a
whole series of processes
in our body that exist to
maintain a steady state,
to maintain the composition
of the interior milieu,
and to ensure that it remains compatible
with all the lives of our cells.
So what are the challenges
that a cell faces?
For a single-cell organism,
like a paramecium or an ameba,
the cell biological and
physiological processes
are one and the same.
In other words, anything
that the cell needs to do
to stay alive is its physiology,
and they're focused on the same goal,
that is maintaining an
organized internal environment
that's distinct from the
inhospitable outside world.
If you're a paramecium swimming in a pond,
your main job is to remain
distinct from the pond, right?
You don't wanna dissolve
and end up distributed
throughout the pond.
So in essence, the major task
for a single-celled organism,
and here I'm going to
tread between science
and philosophy and
theology, but the major job
of a single-cell organism can
be summed up as harvesting
and using the energy that it needs
to maintain the subcellular
structures that it has
that harvest and expend energy.
In other words, a paramecium
exists because it can.
I don't, in any way, want
to discount for those of you
whom it's important for, the
role of divine intervention
in this whole process, but the point is,
something like a paramecium exists
because a paramecium can exist.
It has the structures that
it needs to harvest energy,
whether it's from
sunlight or other sources,
and use that energy to
maintain its composition,
to fight off the urge to
burst and fuse with the pond.
So the challenge for a
paramecium is how to use energy
to solve that problem.
So on the scale of a single-cell organism,
diffusion is fast enough to
ensure that small molecules,
the nutrients that this
paramecium is gonna eat,
for example, can be absorbed
across the cell surface
and readily distributed
throughout the whole cell,
and we call the makeup
of the inside of a cell the cytoplasm.
So the cytoplasm can receive nutrients
directly across the cell's surface,
and that can feed all of
the aspects of the cell
that it needs to feed.
We have exactly the same problem,
but on a hundred thousand
times or more larger scale.
So we have to harvest
the energy that we need
to maintain all of our systems.
Again, our main problem
is to overcome entropy,
to overcome the inevitable forces
that would otherwise lead to
our dissolution and decay.
For those of you who are interested
in graves of famous scientists,
not far from where we are,
in the Grove Street Cemetery, is the grave
of a guy named Jay Willard Gibbs,
who was one of the
founding faculty members
of the Sheffield School, which
subsequently fused with Yale
and became, essentially,
the colonel of its science departments.
Gibbs was sort of the founder
of modern thermodynamics
and developed an equation,
coincidentally named the Gibbs equation,
that explains the relationship
between energy and entropy.
And for those who are
truly devoted to this
and who are interested in doing
a very interesting grave rubbing,
that equation is on his headstone
in the Grove Street Cemetery.
At any rate, we need to invest energy
to overcome the forces of entropy
and to maintain our
composition and our structure.
But because we are far too big
for diffusion to be sufficient
to carry all of the things
we need around our bodies,
we have very complicated
circulatory system
and distributed organ functions
that make all of that possible.
So whereas the paramecium can get by
having everything in
one cell, in one place,
and surviving by diffusion alone,
we have distributed functions
in the form of organs,
each of those organs
connected to each other
by a circulatory system,
and each of those organs
subserving a specified individual function
or series of individual functions
that, were we paramecium,
would be subserved by a
subcellular structure.
For both single-cell organisms
and for complex multicellular
organisms like us,
maintaining compositional integrity
involves controlling the
movement and small molecules
into and out of cells.
Obviously, if you're a paramecium
floating around in a pond,
it's important that water doesn't flow in,
swell you up and cause you to explode,
but it's important also
that you can import
whatever nutrients you want from that pond
so that you can eat and you can export
whatever waste products you generate.
In the case of us, we
are composed of cells,
trillions of cells,
and each of those cells
confronts the same
problem as a paramecium.
Each of those cells, for
all intents and purposes,
lives in a pond or a saltwater bath
that is, what we call, our
extracellular fluid compartment.
So a 60-kilogram person is carrying around
about 36 liters of water,
and that 36 liters of
water is about 0.9% saline,
so about a 10th the
concentration of sea water,
and maintaining that composition
is critically important
to maintaining cell function,
and each cell has to be able
to exchange with that extracellular fluid
what it needs to live on and
what it needs to get rid of.
In your bloodstream
and in your extracellular
fluid compartment is glucose
that your cell needs to create energy,
or amino acids that the
cell needs to make proteins,
the building blocks of the cell structure,
or nucleic acids that the cell
needs to make the DNA and RNA
that it uses to store and
communicate information.
The cell is taking all of
that up from outside of it,
from the extracellular fluid
compartment, and again,
getting rid of any waste
products it might generate.
So each of our cells, for
all intents and purposes,
has exactly the same problem
as these paramecia, paramecii,
and they need to figure out
how to exchange components
with an outside environment,
but maintain their own individual
compositional integrity.
So really, the focus of
this talk is gonna be
what are the cells that
form the interfaces
between our bodies and the outside world?
What problems do they need to solve?
And what structures allow
them to solve these problems?
So I'm gonna introduce you
now to my favorite cell type,
and these are epithelial cells.
Epithelial cells are the
cells that form the barrier
between the inside of you
and the outside of you.
And of course, when I say the barrier
between the inside of you
and the outside of you,
the first thing you think of is your skin,
and that's a good guess.
The skin is an epithelium,
but we have many more epithelia as well.
So if you think about it,
the lumen of your gut,
the inside of your intestine
is really continuous
with the outside world.
If you were flexible
enough and did enough yoga,
you could turn yourself
inside out around your gut
and still be topologically equivalent.
In other words, the inside
of your gut is continuous
with the outside world, and
the cells that line your gut
have to form a barrier
between the inside of you
and the outside of you.
Similarly, the cells in your airway,
your trachea, your lungs
confront the outside world.
Somewhat more subtly,
the cells in your kidney
do exactly the same thing.
So there are all different
variety of epithelial cells
in your body that are forming
all of these different
and interesting interfaces,
and their structure beautifully
reflects their function,
both in forming the interface
and not being simply a
stupid impermeable barrier,
but being an interface
that is able to communicate
with its environment,
import what it needs,
and export what it needs to get rid of.
So epithelial cells are the
barriers between the internal
and external compartments.
They control the composition and body,
or the volume of body fluid compartments,
and they are critically important
to how we maintain our homeostasis.
I told you that you are composed
of about 36 liters of fluid.
Your kidneys are filtering
all of that fluid
five times a day.
So whether you know it or not,
you are making 180 liters
of filtrate in your kidney.
Now, I don't know any of you very well,
except for my wife and
parents who are sitting here,
but I'm gonna guess that you produce
about two liters of urine a day.
That means that your
kidney has to reabsorb 99%
of what it filters.
It's the epithelial cells that do that.
It's the epithelial cells
that are transporting
all of that salt and water,
and their structure is
critically connected
to how they're able to
do that, as we'll see.
So what do epithelial cells look like?
What do they do?
And what are the
morphological or structural
and functional specializations
that let them perform their roles?
So let's start with what do
epithelial cells look like.
They come in lots of
different shapes and sizes.
In cell biology, we define
epithelial cells as squamous,
that means flat, pancake-like,
and then there are cuboidal
and columnar epithelial cells,
and then, what we call, pseudo stratified,
and I'll show you examples of all of them.
What we're looking at here is
frog skin viewed from the top,
and hopefully you share with me,
oh, sorry, you don't see that.
Hopefully you share
with me an appreciation
for just how exquisite this pattern is.
You see these pigment
granules in some of the cells,
and you see that these cells
form a tessellation, a tiling,
a hexagonal array of
cells that fit together
and form a beautiful boundary
that separates the frog from its pond.
And these images actually inspired me
to hang a piece of artwork on my wall
that's by Paul Klee,
called "Ad Parnassus,"
and this is the same image
that was used in the the flyer
that Ty beautifully
prepared for this talk.
This is an image by
Paul Klee that, for me,
reminds me very much of the
structure of an epithelial cell.
Individual cells linked
together in a tiling,
in a tessellation, and each one
with its own individual color structure
contributing to a whole.
And again, connecting art to life,
Parnassus in Greek myth is the
mountain where the muses live
and the origin of art and poetry.
So for me, I love the
idea that that Parnassus,
at least in this image,
connects up to an epithelium,
which is my favorite kind of tissue.
So I told you that the
skin is an epithelium.
This is a section of human skin.
This is the outside.
This is called the stratum corneum,
and this is what faces the outside world.
This is the stuff that is forming
the thickest part of the barrier
that prevents the outside world
from penetrating into you.
It's also the part that
flakes off from time to time
because this stratum corneum is formed
when the cells lower
down in the epidermis,
mature, flatten out, and die.
So here's the epidermis.
These are the cells
that are gonna give rise
to the outer layer of the
skin, and these cells undergo
an amazing process of differentiation.
In other words, of acquiring
a specialized appearance
to fulfill their function.
They start out, and
hopefully you can see this,
as cuboidal cells, and as they migrate up
towards the surface, they flatten out
into these pancake-like squamous cells,
and then become this dead layer
of impermeable material that acts
more or less like a wetsuit
to keep the outside world away from us
and the inside world
away from the outside.
There's beautiful work on the
differentiation of skin cells
being done here at Yale by Valentina Greco
at the medical school, for example.
So we talked a little bit about
what epithelial cells can look like.
I showed you skin, and I also
told you that they can adopt
many different shapes and sizes
that reflect their adaptation
to physiologic roles.
So these are epithelial
cells from the gallbladder.
What I hope you can see is that,
opposed to those skin cells,
these guys are really tall,
and they also form this hexagonal array.
What you're looking at here is,
what's called, scanning
electron microscopy.
It's a specialized form
of electron microscopy
that allows us to
reconstruct cellular shapes
in three dimensions.
What I love about this picture,
what I find really striking,
is if any of you who've
had the good fortune
to travel to Scotland or Ireland
and seen the basaltic
columns, the volcanic columns
of the Giant's Causeway or Fingal's Cave,
you can see the resemblance
between these microscopic cells
and these macroscopic enormous structures
that are formed as lava cools.
And the shapes develop for
essentially the same reason,
which is that hexagons are a great way
to minimize the energy of things
that need to fit together.
Coming back again to Gibbs,
who's buried a few blocks from here,
I find this as a beautiful
example of natural objects
assuming similar structures
at hugely different scales,
and again, seeing the the
connections in these shapes
and the shapes that
we've adopted imitating
these very natural forms
to carry out these physiologic functions.
These are cells of the intestine.
They absorb nutrients, and we'll talk more
about these kinds of
cells in a little bit.
You can see that these are
very tall columnar cells,
and they have this pink
little fuzz on them,
and I'm gonna show you in a minute
what that fuzz is made of.
It's actually hundreds of
individual hairs on each cell,
called microvilli, that
increase the surface area
of these cells and increase
their ability to absorb things,
'cause your intestine is
there to absorb what you eat,
and the more surface area you
have, the more you can absorb,
and these microvilli help
increase that surface area.
These are cells of the airway.
You can see that they have
a different kind of hair
on their surface.
These hairs are called cilia.
You notice that some of
the cells look different.
There are these cells called
goblet cells or mucus cells
that have this clear goop
in the middle of them,
and they secrete mucus.
They're secreting mucus into your airway,
and you may wonder,
especially at allergy season,
why do we have mucus in our airway
that seems aesthetically unpleasing,
and the reason is that
because we are constantly
breathing in stuff
that we don't want in our
body, dust, bacteria, viruses,
if you have a nose like mine, small birds,
and we need to keep
that out of our airways.
The mucus that these cells
secrete lines our airways
and catches that stuff like fly paper.
What I'm gonna show you in a
little bit is that the cilia
on top of these cells are
actually beating like little oars,
and by beating, they're moving that mucus
up towards our mouth and nose
so that we can cough or sneeze it out.
It's called the ciliary escalator.
So these motile cilia
are critically important
to helping us keep pathogens
from entering our bodies
and helping us to get rid of them.
Again, specialized adaptations
that allow us to live
in a hostile world.
So these cells are called
columnar epithelia.
These are pseudo stratified,
pseudo stratified because
these blue blobs, the nuclei,
don't line up in these
cells the way they do here.
It looks like you have
multiple layers of cells,
but in fact, it's one layer
that just is not as well
vertically organized.
So what do epithelial cells
do and how do they do it?
So I need to introduce you
now to some cell biology.
This is a diagram of a
more or less typical cell,
and the first thing I wanna
explain to you is that
just as our body is
surrounded by a layer of skin,
cells have a skin,
but that skin is something
called a plasma membrane
or a cell membrane, and that
membrane forms the boundary
between the inside of the cell
and the outside of the cell.
So it's shown here in pink.
And this pink membrane
is both going to maintain
the compositional integrity of the cell
and determine what gets into it
and what gets expelled from it.
You can also see that there
are lots of other goodies
inside of this cell, lots of
other subcellular structures
that we're gonna talk
about in greater detail.
There's a nucleus, and most
of you are probably familiar
with the idea that the nucleus of the cell
is where the DNA is stored,
and DNA carries the instruction
manual that the cell uses
both to reproduce itself, and
also to encode the production
of every one of the cell's components.
The nucleus is where
the instruction manual
for the cell is stored and
where it's opened and read.
The cell also contains mitochondria.
Mitochondria are
energy-generating structures.
This is where the oxygen
that we breathe is used
to help burn glucose to make energy.
So essentially, our body derives
all of its energy from combustion.
It's a controlled enzymatic
combustion of glucose,
turning that into carbon dioxide,
and using oxygen to help us do that,
and that happens in this
structure called the mitochondria,
which we're gonna talk about much more.
I wanna go a little bit deeper
into the structure of a
membrane before we go on.
These membranes have to serve
a couple of different purposes.
Again, they need to separate
the inside of the cell
from the outside of the
cell, so it makes sense
that you'd want them to
be impermeable to water.
You don't want water to
be able to leak through,
but on the other hand,
they have to be able
to let important things in
and important things out.
We need to let glucose
into the cell, for example.
We need to expel the acid
byproducts of metabolism
out of the cell.
So the cell membrane has to
be both water impermeable,
but selectively permeable to things
that dissolve well in water.
That seems sort of paradoxical.
How do you do that?
So the cell solves this problem
with something called a
phospholipid bilayer membrane.
Lipids are a kind of fat,
and lipids are, of
course, water insoluble.
All of us have had the experience
of working with salad dressing,
and you know that the
olive oil is floating
on top of the balsamic vinegar
and not interacting closely with it.
Membrane is made of very similar stuff.
We know that it's made up of
two layers of phospholipid
because of an experiment that
was done about 100 years ago
by two people in Holland
named Gorter and Grendel.
What they did was
extract all of the lipids
from red blood cells,
and they spread that out
on the surface of a water trough,
and then they measured the surface area
of how much lipid was there,
and they compared that
to the surface area of the red blood cells
that they had extracted
it from, and they realized
that there was exactly
twice as much surface area
as there was surface area
on the red blood cell,
and that meant it had to be a bilayer.
Now, in point of fact, they
miscounted their red cells
and they miscalculated the surface area,
but they were compensating errors,
so they came up with the right
answer for the wrong reasons.
I will say that this structure
is critically important
to how I ended up making a career choice
because when I was in college,
I took a cell biology class,
and the professor reproduced
the Gorter and Grendel experiment
with a little bit of an exciting twist.
He spread out, he took a
trough full of methanol,
and he lit it on fire,
and then he stuck his finger in his ear
to take out some earwax and
dipped it into the trough.
And the idea is that the
earwax is gonna spread out
on the surface of the
liquid, forming a layer
in the same way that Gorter
and Grendel's lipids did
in their trough, and it
would put out the fire
because that lipid would
be impermeable to oxygen,
and that would've been
dramatic and exciting enough
if the professor had not
caught his sleeve on fire.
The vision of a flaming professor
in a cell biology course
was all I needed to dedicate my career.
He survived.
I told you that these
membranes have to function
not only to prevent water
from moving across them,
but also to selectively
let substances like glucose
or ions, et cetera, move through them,
and they do that
because they have embedded
within them proteins.
Proteins are polymers, they're
made up of amino acids,
and essentially the most
important complicated
and interesting structures in our bodies
are all made up of proteins.
Proteins are the engines that
do everything in our body.
All of the enzymes you
hear about are proteins.
All of the structures in
cells are composed of proteins
that endow them with both their structure
and functional capacities.
Proteins are embedded in
membranes, and they can serve
as selective tubes or channels
that let stuff diffuse
into and out of cells.
In fact, they can be
even smarter than that.
They can use energy to actively pump stuff
into and out of cells.
So cells can control
their internal environment
by pumping out stuff they wanna get rid of
or pumping in stuff they need,
and they do that with these proteins
that are embedded in the membrane.
These proteins are linked to each other,
and structural integrity
is provided to the membrane
by virtue of a skeleton,
what's called a cytoskeleton,
that is present beneath
the surface of the membrane
and that acts as a meshwork
that attaches each of these
proteins to each other.
Some of the seminal work
on this was done years ago
by Vince Marchesi in the
pathology department here at Yale,
who characterized the
proteins and the interactions
that mediate the formation of the skeleton
in the red blood cell.
So if we put these components together,
what does a cell look like?
This is a liver cell.
You can see it has a nucleus,
it has some of the mitochondria
we were talking about,
and it's got other structures
like endoplasmic reticulum,
golgi, lysosomes.
So let's look at some of these
in a little bit greater detail.
We're now looking in what we call
a transmission electron microscope.
So we've cut a very, very
thin section of a cell
and we've magnified it
many thousands of times,
and what you're seeing here
is the nucleus of the cell.
The black stuff is the DNA,
the white stuff is material
in between the DNA,
and this nucleus forms a defined structure
sitting in the center of the cytoplasm.
You can also see
that there are these smooth
surface membranes out here,
just next to the nucleus,
and those are what are called
the endoplasmic reticulum,
one of my favorite terms
in cell biology
'cause whenever you say
endoplasmic reticulum,
you sound smart, so it's just
a good word to have on hand.
See these little dots that are sitting
on the endoplasmic reticulum,
these little black blobs?
These were discovered in
the 1950s by George Palade,
who I was fortunate enough to have
as one of my thesis advisors.
And they were identified as the site
in which the cell makes proteins.
So DNA in the nucleus
carries the instructions
for how we make everything in the cell.
Basically, it's the instructions
for how every protein in the cell is made.
Those instructions get copied
down into a little notebook
that gets exported from the
nucleus, called messenger RNA,
or ribonucleic acid, and ribosomes
sit on that messenger RNA
and read that code, and use
that code to make proteins.
That's what's called the
central dogma of biology.
The information in the DNA
is transcribed into RNA,
is read by ribosomes to make proteins.
Now you see that some of
these ribosomes are sitting
on top of the endoplasmic reticulum,
and they're there to solve
a complicated problem
that I didn't mention earlier
on, but that is associated
with these proteins being in a membrane.
How do you get a protein
stuck into a membrane
and organized in the right way?
And the answer is that these
ribosomes can essentially act
as a sewing machine.
As the protein is being made
and emerges from the ribosome,
it's sewn across the membrane
through a special tube
or tunnel that's present in the membrane
of the endoplasmic reticulum
so that proteins can be woven
into the surface of the membrane
and endow the cells
membranes with the proteins
that they're gonna need to carry
out all of their functions.
And actually, it was for
figuring this out that Palade,
along with Günter Blobel,
separately won the Nobel Prize
in physiology and medicine.
Here's endoplasmic reticulum.
Here's another structure that
was discovered by Palade,
again, in the 1960s,
called the golgi complex.
Proteins that get made in
the endoplasmic reticulum
get carried in little cargo vesicles,
little, essentially, packages
that butt off the endoplasmic reticulum,
travel through the cytoplasm,
fuse with the golgi,
and in the golgi,
those proteins undergo
maturation reactions
to help them be prepared
for their next role.
So the golgi complex is the
next step in the assembly line
as these proteins get made
and travel through the cell.
These are pancreatic acinar cells.
These are the cells that secrete
all of the digestive enzymes
that your pancreas makes,
and your pancreas stores those enzymes
in these blobs called secretory vesicles.
Jim Jamieson, who was then a
student in George Palade's lab,
wondered if he could figure
out how proteins travel
from the endoplasmic reticulum, uh-oh,
how proteins travel from
the endoplasmic reticulum
to the golgi complex, to the cell surface.
Because at the time he was
doing those experiments in 1967,
it was not known.
It was known there was
an endoplasmic reticulum,
a golgi, secretory vesicles,
but how did things travel?
So Jamieson did a really smart experiment.
He took pancreatic acinar
and fed them radioactive amino acids.
Now, any protein that's
gonna be made is radioactive,
and at various times after
feeding them radioactivity,
he cut sections of them
and coated them with a
photographic emulsion.
The photographic emulsion
would deposit silver grains
wherever there were radioactive particles.
So basically, by looking at
where the silver grains go,
he could figure out
where the newly synthesized
proteins were traveling.
So hopefully you can see
these black blobs here
are silver grains over
the endoplasmic reticulum.
And when he waited about 10 minutes or so,
you could see that now the black blobs
are over the golgi complex,
and if he waited longer,
they were in immature and then
mature secretory granules.
Jamieson did that experiment as a student
in George Palade's lab.
He actually did it while
Palade was on vacation
'cause Palade really didn't
want him to do this experiment.
He'd set him on another project
that was totally impossible.
Jim wanted to do this experiment.
Palade said no.
Jim did it while George
was away on vacation,
and this result was a big part
of why George won the Nobel Prize.
But Jim received a lot of credit,
so it all worked out in the end.
Okay, so I've introduced
you to components of cells.
Now let's see how they come together
in an epithelium like the kidney.
So this structure here is a glomerulus.
I told you that your kidney filters
180 liters of fluid a day.
You have about a million of
these glomerular structures
in each of your kidneys.
The filtrate that's formed
from this glomerulus
enters a tubule called the nephron,
or the tubule of the
kidney, and these cells
that line the earliest
part of the nephron are,
what we call, proximal tubule cells.
The fluid flows through
the nephron, and again,
about 178 liters of it
is gonna get absorbed
by an assembly line series of processes
that require different
steps at each stage.
And you can see that these
cells of the proximal tubule
look different than cells
of the distal tubule,
of the collecting tubule.
Each of the cell types that
are gonna carry out a function
are specially adapted,
structurally and functionally, to do that.
I want you to pay
attention to the striations
in the base of this cell.
Do you see how interestingly striated
the bottom of this cell is?
We're gonna talk about
that more in a second.
This is what these cells look like
in a transmission electron microscope.
These are the proximal tubule
cells I told you about.
You can see that they've got
something really interesting going on
in the lumen of the tubule.
You can also see that these
cells are full of mitochondria,
huge numbers of mitochondria.
Remember, mitochondria are
where the cells generate energy.
Why does the kidney need so much energy?
Here in the proximal tubule,
here in the distal tubule,
huge numbers of mitochondria.
The answer is that we are
pumping 180 liters of salt water
from the lumen of that kidney
tubule back into your body.
The pumps that do that
burn a huge amount of metabolic energy.
8% of the oxygen consumption
that your body carries out
is used by these
mitochondria and kidney cells
to transport all of that salt
water back into the body.
Let's look more closely
at these microvilli,
these structures on the
proximal tubule cells
that are filling the lumen
of this proximal tubule here.
This is what they look like
in a transmission electron microscope.
You can see they're about a micron long,
a micron being a millionth of a meter
or a thousandth of a millimeter,
and there are hundreds of them
on the surface of the cell.
So this is them at low magnification.
This is them at high magnification.
Here in scanning electron microscopy,
you can see this beautiful
brush-like appearance,
and in fact, this is
called the brush border.
And if you cut cross sections of them,
this is what each of these
guys looks like in the middle.
There are scaffoldings that
run up the middle of it,
and one of the people who's done the most
to figure out what that
scaffold is made of
is a brilliant scientist here
at Yale named Mark Mooseker,
who's in the department
of molecular, cellular,
and developmental biology.
And understanding that
skeleton has been key
to understanding, providing
us an understanding
of how these cells work.
I'm showing you here two different modes
of electron microscopy.
Very excitingly, there's now a third mode
Well, there are many modes
of electron microscopy,
but there's a new one
that's just come to Yale
called focused ion beam
scanning electron microscopy.
What we can do now is take
three dimensional images
through a cell.
Most of you know or have
experienced what a CAT scan is.
A CAT scan, computerized
tomography, allows an X-ray machine
to generate three dimensional
cross-sectional images through you.
Focused ion beam scanning
electron microscopy allows us
to do the same thing on a piece of tissue
on the order of the size of a human hair.
And so what you're looking
at here is a portion
of the inside of one of
these proximal tubule cells,
the orange guys of the
mitochondria, the green guys,
the endoplasmic reticulum, the
yellow is the cell surface.
And now for the first time,
we can appreciate in three dimensions
how all of these structures
are interacting with each other
and talking to each other.
And what you can see is there
are tremendous connections
between these structures,
and we're just starting to understand
how those connections form
and what those connections do.
Now, if epithelial cells
are gonna form a boundary
between the inside of you
and the outside of you,
they have to be connected to each other.
If you put tiles down on a floor,
those tiles need to be
connected to each other
by some sort of grout or something
to keep the outside surface
from getting underneath the tiles.
Cells have junctions
that hold them together.
They have things called tight junctions
that prevent the inside
world from leaking out
and the outside world from leaking in,
and they also have
things called desmosomes
that act as rivets or spot welds,
that hold the cells together
and form the structural integrity
that allows the epithelium to persist.
So this is a cell biologist's
view of epithelial cells.
This is a physiologist's
These are epithelial cells
that are transporting salt.
These are epithelial cells of your kidney,
and they're absorbing
sodium chloride, salt water,
from outside of the
body to inside the body.
And if you rearrange some
of these same transporters,
now you have the cells in
the airway or in the gut
that secrete fluid to keep
the mucus in the airway fluid.
So I'm not gonna go into
any of these details,
I just wanna point out
that those same proteins
that I told you about that
are embedded in the membrane
are serving roles as pumps,
as channels, as carriers
that are moving things
across the membrane,
and where they are in the cell
determines the properties of the cell.
What do those junctions I
told you about look like
in the electron microscope?
This is a modality called
freeze fracture electron
microscopy, where cells are frozen
and they're actually hit
with a guillotine blade
that splits that bilayer
membrane into two.
They're then shadowed with platinum,
and we can see the platinum
in the electron microscope,
and you can see, hopefully,
this beautiful lattice work.
These lattice work are the tight junctions
which are acting essentially
as a garden fence
that prevents the inside from
diffusing into the outside,
the outside diffusing into the inside.
So this structure and the number of lines
in this lattice work correlate beautifully
with how tight these epithelia are.
The more lines we have, the
higher the resistance to flow
between these two domains.
Here's one of those
desmosomes, the spot welds
that give structural
strength to the epithelium,
and you can see that it
looks just like a rivet.
So even though it's at
a tiny microscopic scale
on the order of a fraction of a micron,
it looks just like the kinds of rivets
that you might have in your jeans
that hold your pants together.
I told you about the cilia
that are on the surface
of airway epithelial cells,
these motors that beat
and that move the mucus
towards your mouth and nose.
The same cilia move
eggs through the oviduct
in advance of fertilization.
So there are critical motile
functions to these cilia,
and this is what these cilia look like
in the airway epithelium
in a light microscope,
here's what they look
like in cross-section.
It's an exquisite
structure where you can see
nine rows of, what are
called, microtubules
that are connected to each
other by this lattice work
and to a central pair of microtubules.
And there are motors that
move those microtubules
that slide against one another
and that cause these cilia to beat.
A lot of this was figured
out actually here at Yale
by Joel Rosenbaum, who
did ground-breaking work
on chlamydomonas, which
is actually a motile algae
and has a tail that allows it to swim.
What Rosenbaum figured
out using chlamydomonas
turns out to be critically
important to human disease
because there are people
walking around with diseases
called ciliary dyskinesia
or Kartagener's syndrome
where the cilia don't move,
and those people can have
multiple airway infections,
they can have problems with fertility,
all because of the motors that
move these cilia don't work.
And in fact, polycystic kidney disease,
the disease that Ty mentioned
that our lab studies
is also related to
dysfunctions of the cilia.
Finally, coming back to the
kidney, I want you to notice
that this kidney cell has a
huge mitochondria filling,
almost its whole cytoplasm.
Again, remember these guys need to use
lots and lots of energy
to pump salt and water.
And you can see that the
membrane of the cell is folded
around these mitochondria.
The membrane of these kidney
cells are ruffled, or pleated,
just like if you open a curtain.
If you open a drape, you
get pleats in that drape,
that increases the surface
area of this cell membrane.
So this cell has all of these folds
in order to increase its surface area
so that it can carry
more pumping apparatus
so that it can move that salt and water.
And look, there are mitochondria sitting
right next to those pumps,
prepared to deliver energy to the pumps.
We still don't know how the
mitochondria know to go there.
One of the things I'm excited
about working on in my lab
is trying to understand
who tells the mitochondria
to go to these pleats.
How does the cell know
where it needs its various components?
But another thing that's really exciting
about the work we do in the lab
is just how aesthetically beautiful it is.
These are images of kidney tubules.
In green, we've stained
for the mitochondria,
and you can see the striated structures
I told you about before,
and these cross sections of
kidney tubules correspond
to where the mitochondria are.
Here's a different view of the same thing.
These green circles,
cross-sections of mitochondria.
Here cells grown in a
three-dimensional matrix
that could form a cyst.
And again, you can see
mitochondria traveling
through the whole length of the cytoplasm.
So for me, what I carry away from this
is this beautiful idea
that the form of the cell
very much follows its function,
and we're just beginning to
understand how that works.
We know that all the information you need
to make a cell is present in the nucleus,
and we're still just learning how it is
that that information is
interpreted in each cell type
to make each of these unique structures.
And looking at these unique
structures is both a joy
and a privilege because they're
so exquisitely beautiful.
And bringing me back to the
theme and title of the lecture,
the cells of our bodies have a remarkable,
a beautiful array of structures
whose distribution allows us
to maintain our interior milieu
and allow us to carry our worlds with us.
So at this point, I
wanna thank you very much
for your attention,
and I'd be happy to answer
any questions you might have.
(audience clapping)
- Thank you, Michael.
It was wonderful, I knew it would be.
Thank you, Michael.
Frederick has the microphone,
so we just ask that you
use that for your questions
so all the questions will be
picked up on the video feed.
If I may begin, though,
with the first one,
I've read, and forgive my ignorance,
that mitochondria are,
it came to us through
endosymbiosis, right?
So they were bacteria,
evolutionarily speaking.
So could you talk then a bit
about how maybe that came to be
and what ways in which
they might have addressed,
they might might've developed
solutions for their processes?
Is that similar to the
way epithelial cells have
or, because they were bacteria,
is it a totally different kind of solution
that they developed?
- That's a, sorry.
- So that's a great question,
and there are a number of
layers of answers to that.
So what Ty is referring to is that,
if you look carefully
at those mitochondria,
and if I were to show you
an electron micrograph
of a bacteria, they would
look sort of similar.
And in fact, at a molecular
level, they are kind of similar.
In fact, each mitochondria
has its own DNA.
Each mitochondria has its own
genome that it carries with it
that encodes some but not all
of the proteins that it needs,
and that led to the hypothesis
which has since been abundantly proven
that mitochondria are
bacteria that somehow ended up
being absorbed into and
maintained by our cells.
So we are, what are called, eukaryotes,
or our cells are eukaryotic.
Eukaryotic means cells with nuclei.
Cells without nuclei are prokaryotes.
Somewhere early in the
evolution of eukaryotes,
there were some eukaryotic
cells sitting around,
a whole bunch of prokaryotic cells,
and they somehow endocytosed or absorbed
those prokaryotic cells,
and it occurred to them
that, hey, this works pretty well
because the prokaryotic cells were able
to harvest chemical energy
and produce it in ways
that the cells could use,
and the cells could
provide nutrients and needs
that the prokaryotes use.
Many of you may know that in coral reefs,
the coral polyps have algae
living symbiotically within them.
It's exactly the same thing.
The mitochondria that live within us were,
at one time, free living
bacteria that have now evolved
so close to being a part of us
that they couldn't live without us
and we couldn't live without them.
Now those mitochondria need to address
somewhat different problems
than our whole cell.
They're not concerned with
maintaining the inside of them
and the outside of them because
they live inside a pouch
inside a cell, but they
are actually confronted
with a problem that directly relates
to what they're supposed to do.
They use oxygen to help generate energy.
It turns out that oxygen is really toxic.
That doesn't make a lot of sense, right?
We need oxygen to breathe.
When we're deprived of it,
we start to get really
anxious really fast.
But it turns out that oxygen
is very chemically reactive,
and one of the things mitochondria,
one of the problems they need to solve
is how to prevent themselves
from being damaged
by the oxygen that they're using.
And I won't go into
the biochemistry of it,
but a lot of what mitochondria are doing
is both perfecting the
mechanisms of energy production,
and perfecting the mechanisms
of keeping themselves
from being damaged by
the oxygen that they use.
These little folds inside the mitochondria
are called cristae, and
within those cristae
are the molecular machines
that we use to generate energy.
I won't go into the mechanism now,
but each of those protein complexes
functions exactly like a water wheel.
The principle by which
our body generates energy
is exactly the same principle
that's used by water wheels.
If you drive up to Vermont
and are lucky enough
to still see an old or recreated
water wheel on an old dam,
there's a structure that spins,
and that spinning is exploited
in the same way a
hydroelectric dam exploits
a spinning turbine to
generate, what's called, ATP,
which is the chemical form
of energy that our cells use.
So at any level of resolution
that you look at it,
there are extraordinary
structures, extraordinary machines,
and the engine that generates
that ATP is very, very similar
to the one that's used in bacteria.
- [Audience Member] Hi, what
you were just speaking about,
I'm not a scientist so I'm gonna say
what you were just speaking about,
and also there was a
slide where you discussed
how some people have fertility problems,
and where the, a little
bit like this center photo,
it was, yeah, no.
- Oops, sorry.
- [Audience Member] The
circular one where it's-
- This guy.
- Yeah, it's very orderly as far as
which way these things are
going, it's not random,
and it kind of reminds me of a lecture
that was about why is our
heart on the left side,
and like, you know, everything
else is symmetrical,
and I don't remember the reason why.
Might've had something to do with gravity,
and when the embryo develops or something,
so I wondered if you can
speak a little to that.
- So that is a beautiful question,
and actually uncovers a very subtle point.
So you are absolutely right
that we are mostly bilaterally symmetric.
Our left hand sort of
looks like a mirror image
of our right hand, but
there are organs in our body
that are distributed non uniformly.
Our heart is on the left side,
our liver is on the right side,
spleen is on the left side.
How does that happen?
How do we break that bilateral symmetry?
It turns out that in the
earliest cells of the embryo,
these cilia beat, and
they beat in a structure
called Kupffer's vesicles
to move fluid around
in a precise direction.
It turns out that the
movement of that fluid
in a precise direction,
only in one direction,
is absolutely required to
create our body asymmetry.
And actually beautiful work
is done on that at Yale
by Mustafa Khokha and by Martina Bruckner,
who are understanding the mechanisms
by which the beating
that's created by the cilia
creates a movement of fluid
in this tiny little fishbowl
at the tip of the embryo
that's sensed by antennae,
literally that stick up into it,
and the bending of those antennae
in response to the movement of the fluid
by these cilia is required
for our asymmetry.
And people who have genetic problems
that can't make their cilia move
end up with body parts on the wrong side.
So you can end up actually
with your heart on the right
and your liver on the left.
As long as it happens completely,
you can live a perfectly normal life
and surprise your friends
at parties by saying,
"Hey, listen to my heart,"
and they don't hear it
'cause it's on the other side.
So these ciliary dyskinesias
can produce complete breakdowns
or reversals of bilateral symmetry.
So the cilia are critically important
to not only moving
things through the airway
and the oviduct, but also
during embryonic development.
So that was a very good memory.
- [Audience Member]
Actually, just to follow up
on that (speaks faintly),
but what it is sort of (speaks faintly)
about the inside and the
outside of existence,
sort of, because in that lecture,
they were trying to figure
out why, what's inside of us,
it must have some relation, I mean,
that's like the center of
gravity, like the gravity pull.
Like, it has some relation
to something that's outside
why the heart is where it
is, if that makes sense.
Like, there's some interaction
between we are beings
on an earth with a gravity pull,
so is there anything like that?
- Yeah, kind of.
So when we're standing up,
it's hard for the blood
that's pumped by our heart
down to our legs to come
back up to the heart.
So in fact, when we walk around,
the movement of our muscles,
that squishing movement
helps squeeze blood out of the
veins back towards the heart.
If you sit for a long
time, like in a lecture
where someone is talking
for too long, like I am,
blood can cool in your feet,
and I don't know if
you've ever read the back
of the airplane magazines
where it tells you
on a long flight you're supposed
to move your legs around
so that the blood doesn't pool
in your legs and form a clot.
It is absolutely true
that gravity is a force
that we need to contend with
in order to maintain our circulation.
When you lie down, it's
much easier for fluid
to come back to the heart
than when you're standing up.
Some people who have
trouble with their hearts,
who have something called heart failure,
will find that fluid can
build up in their legs
during the day, and when they lie down,
that fluid moves out of the
legs and returns to the heart,
and actually gets sent to the kidneys,
and they find that they have to get up
in the middle of the night
to urinate many times a night
because the fluid that was in their legs
is now being delivered back to the heart,
is being delivered to
the kidneys, which say,
"Hey, there's too much fluid here.
We need to get rid of some."
So gravity plays a big
part in the specializations
that our body has developed
to move things around
in a world that isn't
completely symmetrical,
if that makes sense.
- [Audience Member] Thank you.
- Sure.
(audience member speaking faintly)
Hi, good to see you.
- [Ty] Do you need the microphone?
- [Audience Member] Yes.
Hi Mike, have you talked
about nephrotic syndrome?
- So I didn't.
So that's a very interesting topic
that I didn't get time to talk about.
Remember, I said that we have
a million of these glomeruli
in each of our kidneys.
Those glomeruli filter the blood
and produce 180 liters of filtrate.
Now, your blood has salt water
in it, it has cells in it,
and it has a lot of proteins in it.
The kidney filtrate has
the salt and the water,
but none of the blood cells
and none of the proteins.
So you've got an amazing
filter in your kidney
that can filter out all of the protein
and let the salt water through.
There's a condition
called nephrotic syndrome
where the ability of that glomerulus
to filter out the protein breaks down,
and now the protein can
end up in the urine.
Now, that wouldn't be such
a big problem by itself,
except we need that protein in our blood
because that protein helps
keep fluid in our capillaries.
There's a complicated mechanism
whereby the presence of
protein in the capillaries
is critically important to
determining the balance of fluid
in our capillaries versus in our tissues.
If we lose the protein in our capillaries,
fluid can flow out into our tissues
and produce huge swelling,
what's called edema.
Patients with nephrotic
syndrome, usually it's children,
will wake up one morning
and be completely swollen.
They look like the
Stay-Puft Marshmallow Man
because now they can't keep
fluid in their capillaries.
It flows out into their tissues.
Fortunately, it's usually self-limited,
can be treated with steroids,
and it goes away as
mysteriously as it comes,
but most of us have probably seen
the very horrifying pictures
of children who are starving,
a condition called kwashiorkor.
Have you ever wondered why those children
have enormously big bellies?
These kids are starving.
Why are their bellies so big?
It turns out that they
don't eat enough amino acids
to make proteins.
They don't have enough
proteins in their blood
to keep the fluid in their capillaries,
and the fluid ends up
pooling in their abdomen.
So it's the same mechanism
as nephrotic syndrome,
except in nephrotic syndrome,
protein is being urinated out,
in protein calorie malnutrition,
protein isn't being made.
But there's a critical physiologic force
called the Starling force
whereby protein is necessary
to keep fluid in capillaries,
and that's lost in nephrotic
syndrome when protein is lost
in the urine.
So thank you for the question.
Mother.
(audience laughing)
Yes, is the answer.
- [Mother] First of all,
I'm very proud of you.
- Thanks you.
(audience clapping)
- [Mother] Secondly, I have always been,
since I was a child, very
fascinated by Darwin,
and how we evolved
because we needed things.
How can you take a
structure like the kidney
or even what you
described that's so minute
and apparently so important,
and how does the body know,
or how did the evolutionary workings know
that this little minute thing
that goes around in a circle
is necessary to do the next thing?
- Right.
So the question is how
could something so beautiful
and intricate arise from
random experimentation,
and right, this is the question
that motivates the debate
between intelligent design
and Darwinian evolution.
And the answer is, and there's
very good evidence for it,
that this happens by a lot, a lot, a lot
of random experimentation,
random mutation over time
that produces huge numbers
of different changes,
most of which don't work,
but the ones that do work
give each cell or each
organism a selective advantage
that allows it to use that
structure to do better,
and that structure can then get improved
by the next change or
mutation, et cetera, et cetera.
So in response to Ty's question,
I mentioned that these
mitochondria used to be bacteria.
Bacteria have a lifespan
that's measured in,
you know, hours to days, right?
So bacteria should not invest
in long-term savings bonds or anything.
They're turning over
really, really quickly.
They're dividing incredibly quickly.
They undergo huge numbers of mutations,
random changes in their DNA.
Most of those mutations don't
do these bacteria any good,
and their bacteria offspring
are not going to succeed,
but the ones that do succeed,
that build a better way
to harvest energy, to make chemical energy
that cells can use, they're gonna have
a huge selective advantage
and they're going to become
the most important bacteria in the slime.
And so those mechanisms
have been proven beautifully
through, what we call, directed evolution.
There's a whole science
now that was started
by a woman named Frances Arnold,
who won the Nobel Prize
for this, who said,
"Well, if evolution can work this way,
maybe we can use it for our advantage."
Maybe we can convince
bacteria to do new things
that they couldn't do
before, like eat oil spills,
or chew up plastic, or
make proteins that we need
for biomedical uses.
So what she and her
colleagues and the people
who have followed
through on the principles
that she developed have done
is to just expose bacteria
to chemicals that would mutagenize them,
and then come up with a way
of selecting for the bacteria
that have the properties they want,
and saying, "Look, I don't care
how you figure this out, bacteria,
but I want one of you to
figure out how to chew up oil.
Get back to me when you've done it."
And so we can actually speed up evolution
by increasing the rate
of random mutagenesis,
and increasing the rate
of natural selection.
So not only does it work,
not only is that the way this happened,
but we can actually engineer
it and use it to our advantage.
- [Audience Member] A little scary.
- Yeah, everything
nowadays is a little scary.
(audience laughing)
- [Ty] Would you go
back to the cilia slide?
- Sure.
- [Ty] Everyone's favorite
slide, apparently.
Are cilia throughout the body
thusly organized with the ring of nine?
Are all cilia like this?
And they're distinct
from microtubules, right?
Do microtubules in
cross-section look the same way,
or do they differ depending
on their location?
- Right, so here are
microtubules in cross-section,
and you can see that there are
parallel arrays of filaments
that happen to be made up
of a protein called actin
that fills these filaments,
about a few dozen of them per microtubule.
Microvilli can move,
but nowhere near as well
and nowhere near as coordinated as cilia.
Cilia are made up of these
arrays of microtubules
that are made up of a
protein called tubulin,
and connected by radial spokes
that hold those tubules together,
and motors called dynein
and kinesin that use energy
to make these motor, these
tubules beat in a systematic way.
There are two kinds of cilia in your body.
There are the movable cilia
that we call motile cilia,
that have nine rings of
tubules and a central pair.
And then there are non-motile cilia,
what we call the,
well, the non motile cilia,
which is present in almost
every cell in our body.
It doesn't beat, but it
acts like an antenna.
In fact, in the kidney,
each cell has a cilia
that's sticking out into the lumen,
and as fluid flows past it,
it bends like a reed in a stream,
and screwing up the
sensing of that fluid flow
is part of what leads to
polycystic kidney disease.
And beautiful work on that has been done
by Steve Somlo here at Yale, among others.
But sensory cilia or
primary cilia are involved
in sensing chemicals,
sensing physical stimuli.
So the cells in our eye that detect light,
the light sensors are
actually a specialized cilium.
In our nose, the chemo sensors
that detect smells are
a specialized cilia.
So there are mechanically and
chemically sensitive cilia
that look just like this,
except they don't have the
central pair and don't move.
But a subset of tissues in
our body have motile cilia,
like the airway, like the oviduct,
and those use cilia in a different way
to create this fluid flow,
to create this motion.
(audience member speaking faintly)
- [Audience Member] And it's a little,
like a little misty, foggy, unconnected,
but you had a slide,
well, it's basically the question about
why is kidney disease, nephrititis or,
isn't that the root is death, where,
you know, other diseases, you
have appendicitis or pancrea,
but you had a cell facet, it was purple,
that was had the neph.
I just wondered, is there
relation in the naming of things
that kidney disease was actually equated
with like sure death
or something, whereas-
- Yeah, well, so prior to 1960-something,
if you lost kidney function,
you were gonna die.
There was not a lot that
could be done for you.
In the 1960s, renal dialysis was developed
so that people who had kidney failure,
the functions of the kidney
to get rid of waste products
and to maintain salt and water
balance could be maintained
by dialyzing the blood, that
is running it through a machine
and doing the same cleaning process
that the kidney normally does.
And then subsequent to that,
the development of
transplantation medicine
allowed the replacement
of an ailing kidney
with a donor kidney,
if someone is fortunate enough to get one,
but the kidney is far and
away not the only organ
whose dysfunction can lead
to serious disease or death.
I mean, obviously,
that's true of the heart,
that's true of the brain.
It's also true even of the pancreas.
If you lose the ability
to secrete insulin,
that could limit your
lifespan basically to weeks,
and back in the days before
the discovery of insulin,
there was no way to treat someone
who had type one diabetes.
In fact, the first discussion
of the discovery of insulin
and its ability to reverse the
symptoms of type one diabetes
was a lecture delivered
here at Yale 102 years ago
by Banting of Banting and Best,
the discoverers from Toronto
who discovered insulin
and presented it at Yale
at a meeting of the American
Physiological Society.
So Yale played a minor role
in at least disseminating that discovery,
if not in the making of the discovery.
So yeah, I mean, we
have lots of body organs
and we need them.
They each do different things.
Just like the different
components of a cell are required
to keep that cell working and healthy,
each of our organs are required
to keep the whole body
working and healthy.
- [Audience Member] So is there something
about why the purple
one we call the nephros?
Is that a coincidence, or is it-
- So the Greek word for kidney is nephros,
and the structures,
the tubules of the kidney
are called nephrons,
so you have a million nephrons
in each of your kidney.
Those nephrons are long
tubes of epithelial cells
that carry out all of this
salt and water transport.
Sure.
- [Ty] And I think the root
maybe you were thinking of
is necro for death, right?
Like necrosis, like necrotic.
- [Audience Member] Yeah.
- [Ty] So that's a Greek root for death.
- [Audience Member] Thank you.
- [Ty] Okay, any other questions?
Okay, well thank you.
Please join me again.
Thank you, Michael, for a wonderful talk.
(audience clapping)
(gentle music)